We're continuing our partnership with
learn liberty this week and joining me
today as a senior fellow at the Mercatus
Center at George Mason University,
as well as a professor of economics at
George Mason.
Don Boudreaux,
welcome to the Rubin report.
Happy to be here.
I am glad you are here.
I saw you speak about a year ago in
Dallas.
I want to get the exact title of the
speech right.
Uh,
it was called,
can we bring sound economic thinking to
Washington?
That's a tough task.
That was a year ago and uh,
I don't think there's much sound
economic thinking or sound thinking and
Washington,
forget economics for a second.
These things don't seem to go together
these days.
Uh,
Washington seems to repel something.
It attracts unsound thinking.
Yeah.
Well,
you think it was always that way,
or are we in unique times?
What?
We're definitely a unique talent and
unique time.
So I was born in 1958,
so I came of age right when Ronald
Reagan,
right at the end of the Carter
administration,
when even Carter's pushing for direct,
at least accepting deregulation taxes
were being cut airline to being
deregulated surface transportation is
being deregulated.
Reagan gets elected in 1980.
Milton Friedman has this popular show on
pbs called free to choose a Thomas.
I learned about Thomas Soul.
Everything seems great.
And there was,
this world is fine.
And uh,
so in my life in my life,
there was a period in the past when the
thinking was more sound quibble with it,
but compared to today it was,
it was outstanding because it's
definitely,
it's definitely declined.
Yeah,
it's hard to imagine even that around
the time of Jimmy Carter that
deregulation,
I mean that,
that Democrats could have had anything
to do with that.
And yet the Ted Kennedy was a major
force behind airline deregulation.
So it was,
it was something,
I'm not sure what it was exactly.
It was something in the air,
uh,
starting in the late seventies.
And so,
you know,
I was a young man then I just took it
for granted,
this is fine,
you know,
we were winning and then it culminates
in 1989 with the collapse of the,
of the,
of the Iron Curtain in 1991,
the collapse of the Soviet Union.
And then here we are 2018 and a lot of
nonsense is back on the front burner.
Nonsense is back.
So let's jump back though to the
seventies for a second because I watched
an interview with you this morning.
Something happened to you I believe in
1977 that,
that woke you up.
And I think it sort of is a nice entry
into everything else that,
you know,
I know what you said.
Yeah.
I said is most important to what
happened to you in 1977?
You can come up with a couple of
options.
They don't know.
The date was,
was,
was January 24th,
1977.
I remember it was a um,
I,
I was in college.
I went to police.
My mother,
my plan was to drink beer,
chase girls.
I did a lot of the former,
I wasn't successful with the ladder,
but I was then I was going to drop out
of college and work at the shipyard
where my parents worked,
so I needed a class to fit my schedule
and needed the Monday,
Wednesday,
Friday class.
So take this class called economics,
didn't know what it was,
took it and uh,
I had a great teacher and so she drew
supply and demand curves on the board
and she said,
look what happens when the government
prevents the price of something from
rising to its market level,
it creates a shortage.
She says,
you remember the gasoline shortages of
1973.
So yeah,
I was in those and I just thought the
beauty of this economic explanation for
the gasoline shortage was so
spectacular.
I wanted to learn more about the
subject.
And so in very short order,
I just fell in love with economics.
I'm still in love with it to this day.
Yeah.
So tell me what happened after that.
So now you have your spar and what,
what sort of,
what academic procedures did you have
that got you to where you are?
Was very lucky.
Again,
she was a really good teacher and it
wasn't a famous economist at all.
She was a very good teacher.
She took a great interest in her
students.
She taught economics as if it was
something relevant to the real world
rather than just a mathematical puzzle.
Uh,
and there was another guy at my I went
to puts called Nicholls State University
and Tibideau Louisiana and it says it's
a very small school,
but I had another professor there who
was into Milton Friedman into high Eq,
into Ludwig von mises into James
Buchanan,
who later became my colleague at George
Mason.
So I would go to his office,
his name is bill field,
and he would give me these books.
And so I remember just really just
tearing through these books and it just
made so much sense to me.
I realized in reading these books that
all my life,
I didn't give much thought to politics.
Not much conscious thought,
but all my life,
uh,
I think somewhere deep inside of me was
a classical liberal or libertarian,
someone who believed that is basically
impolite to button to other people's
business.
Uh,
and,
and not only impolite,
I mean it's,
it's downright,
it's downright offensive to do so.
Yeah.
You just said to him,
my buzz phrases,
so classical,
liberal and Libertarian.
Now,
one of the questions I get most because
I define,
I say that I am a classical liberal if I
need,
if I need a label on it,
that's what I am.
And people will always say to me because
I talk about many of the things that you
teach about,
about free markets and all that stuff,
and I believe that freedom is the best
way for humans to flourish.
People say,
Dave,
you're really a libertarian.
You're just holding onto this definition
of liberalism from 18,
whatever.
Do you see a meaningful.
How would you define each one and do you
see a meaningful distinction?
I don't see much of a distinction.
Depends on who you talk to.
Some people see,
see distinctions.
I think what they both have in common,
maybe distinctions that the margin
libertarians maybe tend to be a little
bit more radical,
uh,
but uh,
a,
what distinguishes classical liberals
and Libertarians as broadly from almost
any other political group,
a,
is the consistent,
uh,
believe that any exercise of power by
the state must meet a huge burden of
proof.
Uh,
the,
the burden of proof is not upon the
individual to make the case his or her
freedom.
It's upon the state to make the case,
to Intro to,
to override that freedom.
And I believe in libertarian or
classical liberals as I think of them,
believed that that burden is a real one
and it's a heavy one.
Sometimes it can be met,
but too often the reverse is in place.
People believe that you have to,
that the burden is on those of us who,
who defend freedom to make the case for
freedom.
And I think it's backwards.
So basically you view it as sort of a
bottom up way of looking at things.
It's about the individual first and the
government is not giving you your
freedom.
It can take it away,
however,
by instituting all sorts of policies.
Yeah,
I,
I'm in this case,
I am A.
I think John Locke was right in John
Locke,
wasn't the only person he put John Lott
most famously in a,
made the argument in this,
in the secondary of some government
that,
um,
uh,
you know,
human beings have rights and human
beings delegate to the government,
uh,
powers that you,
that,
those who do the delegation believe are
appropriate for the government to defend
those rights.
Um,
you can quibble about how historically
accurate that is,
but I like,
I think that perspective is
philosophically correct.
Uh,
no government gives me or you rights
governments are excellent at offending
rights and taking them away.
Uh,
but,
but just because government is to
protect your rights doesn't mean he
gives us rights just because farmers,
because we couldn't live without
farmers,
if no one grew food and,
and,
and did ranching,
we would all starve.
That doesn't mean that we owe our lives
to farmers.
Uh,
one of the great things about the
society that we live in is that it's a,
it was called the great society to be
distinguished from when the Johnson's
great society and that is,
it is a society of many,
many individuals each specialized in
doing various things.
We're all coordinated by the price
system in,
by the rule of law.
Uh,
and so each of us makes a contribution
to the welfare of others,
but no one of us is utterly essential.
And that's a really good system,
I believe.
Yeah.
So I want to talk more about hiking a
little bit because you do run the cafe
high Eq blog.
Uh,
you mentioned the burden of proof that
the government has to meet to say when
it's right to actually infringe on some
of your rights or basically do things.
Yeah.
So this is where I would say the
classical liberal and Libertarian
positions that are a little bit
different.
I see some utility for the state,
although I'd usually want it done at
the,
at the state level,
not the federal level and libertarians.
It's sort of hard to pin on when it's
enough.
And you alluded to that when you talk to
libertarians,
how do you get to a place where,
where it's not,
you know,
I always make the joke,
it's like eventually you'll just be in
mad max or the true anarcho capitalists,
which I enjoy talking to,
but I view it as more of an intellectual
exercise than a practical.
Yeah,
I mean,
I,
I'm very sympathetic anarcho and
philosophically I'm,
yeah,
but I'm not a,
I'm not a,
a,
a blow things up kind of guy and I'm way
too much of a hierarchy.
And to understand that you just can't
replace social institutions.
Wholesale Society has to evolve to
wherever it's going to be from March,
from being a realist.
I mean,
you couldn't blow it up.
I say,
Oh,
well,
yes you could.
But history has a lot of really telling
examples about attempts to blow up
societies wholesale in those examples
have never turned out well in practice.
Uh,
let me say among the people who will
call themselves classical liberals,
right?
None of them are ever at a w,
whatever,
express any sympathy for animal
capitalism among Libertarians.
Some of them will say,
oh no,
I,
I believe there's a role for the
government,
but you do it.
People who classify themselves as
Libertarians who say,
at least,
at least in principle,
I believe that the society could exist
without any formal institution have
monopolized coercion and I,
I am in that latter latter.
Yeah.
I might be the one classical liberal who
will do it,
or maybe that.
Maybe by that definition I'm a little
more libertarian,
but again,
these things.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
We're,
you know,
it's really sort of the narcissism of
small differences in exactly in this
little place.
All right,
so what are some of the basic
principles?
You're a professor,
what are the basic principles that
people should know about economics?
I know I'm giving you a wide one there,
but for someone watching this,
that that's waiting for their 19,
77 moment.
So in no particular order,
right?
Number one,
scarcity is unavoidable.
We live in a world of scarce resources,
which means that if you use some
resources to do this good thing,
you take resources away from the ability
to do other good things.
They both good things,
but we have to choose do we want to do
this good thing or do we want to do
that?
Good thing.
Second thing to note in order to make
that decision,
uh,
we want the people involved who are
going to be affected both by the loss of
that which is not done and by the
benefit of that which is done to express
their opinions honestly,
how,
how valuable is this thing that we
propose to do and how valuable is this
thing that we propose to give up in
order to do this first thing?
And,
and to do that,
we,
you,
you need people on the ground who are
actually affected by these decisions to
have a,
a meaningful say.
You don't want a third party looking
down making declarations.
Oh,
I think you should have that.
And I think you should not have had
that.
So any social mechanism that gives each
of us as much of a say as possible in
how we use resources and,
and,
and make the evaluations about what
will,
what will happen if we use resources in
this way and what will give up if we use
resources in this way that that's
important.
Unintended consequences is another
important concept.
Uh,
you know,
Adam Smith in the wealth of nations
which is rightly considered to be the
start starting point of modern
scientific economics.
He,
he famously talked about the invisible
hand and this is,
is this the sort of an unintended
consequences kind of explanations,
not from the benevolence of the butcher,
the brewer there,
Baker that we expect our dinner,
but from their regard to their own
interests,
they don't dislike you.
They value as a customer,
but they are doing their jobs,
not primarily to help you.
They're doing their jobs to help
themselves and you are buying from them,
not primarily to help them,
but primarily to help you and your
family.
And in that way,
everyone's either.
So this is a good unintended
consequence,
but you have,
you have bad unintended consequences as
well as one of my favorite examples of a
bad unintended consequences.
The minimum wage raise the minimum wage.
It looks like you helping low skill
workers if you might help some of them,
but in fact you putting other low
skilled workers out of jobs and you're
keeping them out of the job market for
longer.
And so economists think what makes a
good economist,
which distinguishes a good economist
from a bad economist or non economist
is,
is a consistency and asking questions
always asking as compared to what?
As compared to what,
where did that come from?
How are we going to pay for that?
What did this cost,
uh,
what will be the longterm consequences
down the road beyond the immediate ones
that,
that everyone can see.
So it's just a,
it's just a consistency and asking those
questions.
You know,
it's funny,
as you're answering the question,
it keeps making me think,
well,
this shows you why politics is so
screwed up because they get up,
they're all politicians on either side
and they either say $15 minimum wage,
Bernie or trump,
I'm going to cut taxes on you.
Or they,
you know,
they loved their bumper sticker stuff,
but nobody's ever said unintended
consequences in a presidential debate.
So how frustrating less that be as an
economist,
listening to people who are not
economists who really aren't experts in
much of anything,
I don't know that Bernie has ever
created a business or made anyone make a
dollar off and I'm not aware of it
overnight.
But that must be incredibly frustrating
to hear non pros talk about the things
that you're a pro at.
It is Dave and you know,
it's especially frustrating about it.
It's not rocket science.
I mean,
I love economics.
I love my profession and I really admire
the best among my professional
colleagues,
Milton Friedman and high Eq.
But it's not rocket science.
It's just this consistency of always
understanding that there are
consequences beyond the immediate,
uh,
that,
that there's always a cost to something,
uh,
that no matter how beneficial something
is,
it has to be weighed against that cost.
So these simple,
a simple understanding and the
consistency and applying that
understanding,
it's not difficult,
but so few people do it.
So it is,
it is frustrating.
You.
Years ago I stopped.
I,
I joke that I stopped watching the
evening.
People my age used to watch the evening
news,
right?
I remember it.
I have some recollection,
hey man,
I had to stop watching the news.
I was always threatened to throw my
shoes through the,
through the screen because the
reporters,
they would very much like the
politicians,
they would report on the immediate
effect,
Oh,
the minimum wage is going to rise.
That that means that workers will get a
raise of whatever the amount is as well.
What it does it,
it means that for some workers,
but it means also other workers are
gonna lose their jobs.
Some jobs,
the nature of those jobs are going to
change.
Employers aren't just going to sit back
and say,
oh,
well we've got to pay higher minimum
wages,
so let's just be higher minimum wage.
Where's that money coming from?
Where are those resources coming from?
They have to come from somewhere.
Yeah.
So basically your argument would be that
the government's only role in the
economy is to make sure we're not
killing each other pretty much.
Right?
Like it really it's a total laissez
faire at.
Yes.
I am a very laissez faire guy if,
if property rights are well defined and
secure,
and there's a strong case of government
plays a role of Ken play,
a role in helping to define and
certainly helping to secure property
rights.
So that's where your contract rights.
So that's where you're not in Oracle
capitalists,
right?
Well,
I'm,
I'm close to being right.
I mean,
I,
I'm,
I'm willing.
I'm willing to admit that we're
gradually giving that to Devon.
I'm willing.
I'm willing to admit that anarcho
capitalism might not be a,
uh,
ultimately a defensible position.
I am not willing to admit that free
markets are an indefensible position.
However,
property rights come to be.
they are defined,
however they are enforced when you have
secure private property rights and
freedom of contract,
which includes importantly the freedom
to say,
no,
I have the freedom to not contract.
Uh,
then people are led to pursue their
people in pursuing their own interest,
are obliged to help others out.
And that's how this great society that
we live in and it is great,
uh,
continues to grow and become more
prosperous.
Yeah.
So I mentioned to you right before we
started that,
you know,
I've had a political awakening of sorts
and I always say to people,
I didn't really move,
but the left went so bananas.
I ended up being friends with all these
Libertarians and conservatives and
whatever,
whatever it is,
even for the differences we may have,
but one place I have shifted is that I
am much more aware you are economically
now and partly that's because I now run
my own business and have employees and
have to deal with that.
And I just wrote to obscene lehigh
checks for taxes for the year.
I mean,
we are in California.
You don't want to know him like that one
was in the federal loans even worse,
and it's like you're more successful.
I get the harder I work,
the more they want to take from you.
And I tweeted something about that on
tax day and a lot of people were angry
at me and said,
well,
it's,
this is the price to pay for success.
Would you rather be poor?
And I didn't want to go on a major tweet
storm and you wisely or not on twitter,
but could you,
could you give me something that,
if I ever get in that fight again,
I can say to people why that's not the
right way to think.
So let me start off with just asking
you.
Have you heard the story about George
Mcgovern when he retired from politics?
He a big sale,
please say,
so George Mcgovern,
he retired from politics.
I think I have the details right.
He certainly had the major part of it.
He started the BNB,
uh,
you know,
in,
in his home state already.
Like where this is going.
Yeah.
And,
uh,
then he encounters all these
regulations,
you know,
labor regulations,
safety regulations,
uh,
and he admits,
I can't remember now to whom he admitted
as a long time ago.
He didn't,
he,
he admits,
he said,
you know,
I've spent all my,
I'm not quoting him,
I'm going from memory.
So I spent all my life pushing for these
things.
I was sufficiently attentive to the
downside of,
of,
of these taxes and these regulations.
And so it's easy to,
you know,
to sit in Sacramento to sit in
Washington dc to sit in some,
you know,
local government,
a office building and tell other people
how to live and to tell other people how
much money they have to give to you.
And you can be well intentioned in the
best sense of the term,
but you are not those other people and
those other people are bearing
consequences and they know of things
that you don't understand.
And so on,
on the,
on the tax thing,
I like what,
uh,
my friend Ed Crane said about,
the famous quotation that is above the
door of the IRS building in Washington.
It's a quotation from justice Oliver,
Wendell Holmes who said,
I think this exact quotation,
taxation is the price you pay for
civilization.
And Crane says,
no,
that's wrong.
Taxation is the price we pay for being
insufficiently civil law.
Civilization is,
is when we cooperate peacefully to help
each other.
And so even if we grant that there is
some role for government and once you
granted some role for government,
it's very difficult to not see that
there's some appropriate level of
taxation to fund that role for
government.
Uh,
how much that may be true that we need,
that it represents a failure of us as a
society to become fully civilized.
We've somehow not managed to figure out
how to cooperate peacefully and
voluntarily in those matters in ways
that we have managed to discover how to
cooperate peacefully and voluntarily and
doing what we're doing here today and
going to the supermarket and the
supermarket dealing with the various
suppliers that,
that it has.
None of that is,
is funded with taxation,
so all funded with voluntary voluntary
payments.
That is civilization.
So I liked the notion that the taxation
is a,
it's,
it's sort of a measure of how little we
are civilized or how far we have to go
to be completely civilized to make sure
we're not killing each other.
Yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
So.
All right.
I want to get back to a couple things
you said there.
So first.
Okay.
I know that I know that the minimum wage
is,
is a big one for you.
And even just this morning I write
another story about how Bernie wants
this $15 minimum wage.
The anecdote that I keep using or
anecdote that I keep using is that I
keep traveling,
traveling all over the country right
now,
and in almost every airport you go to
fast food places and they don't have
people anymore.
They have ipads.
Yes.
Now perhaps if you could pay people
less,
people would have jobs.
It wouldn't be the greatest job in the
world,
but it would be the way it's always
worked.
Now we are literally replacing people
with robots that may be inevitable no
matter what,
but to say that you have to pay people
again,
even from my own business here,
I get people offering to work for me for
free all the time.
I want to pay people appropriately and
we do pay all our people.
Um,
but the idea that the government would
force me to pay someone x amount,
it seems completely bananas.
Yeah.
So
the minimum wage,
uh,
puts low many low skill workers,
auto jobs.
If,
if,
uh,
a teenager is not worth $7 and twenty
five cents per hour,
employers who are not in the charity
business are not going to hire that
teenager at that price,
that teenager will go without a job or
go without a job in the,
in the above ground economy,
make find a job paying more in the
underground economy,
which is a different set of problems.
Uh,
and so that is the major unintended
consequence of the minimum wage there.
There are others,
but that,
that's the big one.
Um,
and if,
uh,
you know,
what people like Bernie Sanders,
I mean,
because I speak to proponents of the
minimum wage all the time with most of
them do,
they just stopped the analysis at the
surface.
Oh,
wouldn't it be better to be paid $15 an
hour and said,
of course.
So this is,
they don't want to get to the unintended
consequences,
but I think because I think because most
of them believe that they just had this
image of employers as being a really
rich,
a highly profitable operations.
And so if you raise the minimum wage,
oh sure,
it has a cost,
but the cost that's going to be born
exclusively by employers,
but it's a fact.
Most low skilled workers work in highly
competitive industries.
They work in food retail,
you know,
they work at lawn care,
they,
they work in,
in,
in supermarkets,
restaurants.
These are highly competitive industries.
So there's no big profit margin.
They are.
So when you raise the minimum wage is
not coming out of the profits of the
employers.
It has to come out of some change in the
way the employers do their business.
There's nothing wrong with automation,
of course.
Yeah.
But there's a,
there's a proper amount of automation
and if you raise the minimum wage,
you get too much automation,
uh,
because you put and too few human
workers.
And here's,
I just want to make this clear,
here's another unintended consequence of
the minimum wage.
And not only does it deny income to
those workers who lose their jobs worse
in most cases,
it denies those workers would what's
even more valuable,
namely the opportunity to get that first
piece of job experience.
And so the 16 year old who otherwise
would have gotten the job without the
minimum wage becomes a 17 year old or 18
year old who's still a never employed
person.
Whereas otherwise they would have had
job experience.
And so it,
it,
it swells,
officially swells the ranks of,
of,
of unskilled workers.
Would there be a direct correlation then
once you have this whole set of people
at this imaginary $15 minimum wage,
they are also going to raise prices on
basic things,
right?
I mean,
is there a direct correlation?
Price prices may rise a little bit
because you get,
you know,
the economy's a little bit less
efficient and so you get a little bit
less output,
but the price increases aren't,
aren't the major problem.
The major problem is employers will find
ways to satisfy their customers,
uh,
at slightly higher cost to the
employers,
but at huge cost to those workers who,
who lose their jobs.
So when you've talked to kind of miss on
the left that disagree with you on this,
and I get what you're saying,
that they're not taking that next step.
I'm sure there's someone out there that
has made a sound argument that you just
disagree with you.
So there is one sound argument,
one sound theoretically,
one theoretically coherent argument for
the minimum wage.
And that is if employers have what's
called monopsony power vent,
then I'm going need you to find that
one.
Yes,
monopsony power.
It's like monopoly power.
Except so monopolist is the only seller.
A monopsony says the only buyer.
Okay?
So if you're the only buyer of low skill
workers in the market,
but you as an employer,
you then can be easily shown.
You can keep wages lower than they would
otherwise be too low.
And given that you,
it can be then shown that if the
government comes in and sets a minimum
wage right,
then,
uh,
the employer will in fact pay the higher
minimum wage and no employees will be
harmed.
But it's a very,
very strict criteria are very,
very strict.
And the idea that that Walmart and
Mcdonald's and Burger King and KFC and
all the mom and pop restaurants and and
made services and lawn care services
that we have throughout the United
States,
the idea that any one of these is a man
alone monopoly buyer of low skill
workers is just absurd.
All right,
so one of the things that you write
about a lot is that the idea of middle
class stagnation is actually wrong.
Yes.
We hear this all the time from
politicians for I think my whole life
that I was ever caring about politics.
It's always that the middle class is
shrinking and the extremes are getting
bigger,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
But you actually take a different
position on it.
Yeah.
This middle class stagnation thesis is
stated as if it's an established fact
with no arguments against it.
It's just,
it's just wrong.
I think you were born in the mid
seventies,
right?
Seventy six.
Okay.
So according to this thesis,
it was.
It was right around that time,
mid seventies when.
Apologize.
That's okay.
It was your fault.
So the American middle class had been
chugging along,
upward hits the mid seventies,
and then it's been stagnant ever since.
So ordinary Americans today,
so goes the thesis lived no better than
ordinary Americans lived when Gerald
Ford was in the Oval Office.
I think this is crazy.
I mean,
I have,
I'm,
uh,
unfortunate old enough to remember the
19 seventies and although one zone
personal experiences shouldn't be a
basis for scientific conclusions,
they're not irrelevant thing.
I know I come from a working class US
family.
I remember how we lived in the
seventies.
I remember what cars were like.
I remember when television was like,
or what healthcare was like,
things are a lot better today for
ordinary Americans.
And so a number of years ago just
started looking into this,
this thesis,
uh,
the,
our data that you can find that the
people who propose this thesis a point
to,
uh,
that,
that lends some superficial credence to
the thesis.
But here's just some of the problems
with these data.
Uh,
they adjust for inflation in ways that
vastly overestimate the amount of
inflation that we've had since the mid
seventies.
So mean vastly under counting the growth
in real incomes since the seventies.
A lot of these data,
we'll look at household incomes,
uh,
well,
the,
the typical population of the American
household has fallen since the mid 19
seventies.
Today it didn't sound like much,
but today it's about 11 percent lower
than it was in 1975 a.
But that's actually a pretty
significant.
So the same amount of income and a
household and it was spread over fewer
people.
And so the individual individual people
are,
are richer,
meaning we're just not having as many
kids that we're not having as many kids.
We were becoming wealthier so that now,
well maybe not in the last 10 years or
so,
but for much of this period,
uh,
younger people I've been able to move
out of their family,
their parents homes at a younger age and
start the households younger,
uh,
older people are able to continue to
live by themselves rather than moving
with their,
with their children.
The quality of goods and the variety of
goods and services that Americans,
ordinary Americans have access to today
is astonishing compared to what it was
just 40 years ago.
I actually spent a lot of time looking
at catalogs from the mid 19 seventies,
you know,
sears roebuck catalogs,
and then you can look@sears.com
today and you can look at the prices
that we charge back that course.
Nominally they will lower,
but then you just take those prices and
you divide them by the wage that the
average American earned back then and do
the same thing for the prices today and
divided by the wage of the average
American owns today.
And what you find in almost all cases is
that the amount of time it takes to work
in order to earn enough income to buy a
pair of jeans,
a shirt,
a washer and dryer,
and an airplane ticket is dramatically
less.
Today.
American.
We don't have to work as much today as
we did back then in order to get the
things that make our standard of living
as high as it is.
So did they.
Just the people that believe in this,
that they just do a great sell job.
I mean,
how did this meme,
how did this idea get out there?
Because you hear this all the time.
This is one of the few things that you
hear on both sides of the aisle.
Yes.
Yeah.
And in fact,
I,
uh,
yes,
I think the Paul Krugman says it all
says it all the time and I think in a
way kind of backfire when people in the
left because they keep saying it.
And I believe that's one thing that
helped the drum ups popular support for
Donald Trump.
You know,
middle class Americans have been
stagnating.
So let's do something about it.
Let's electronic.
There's an interesting psychological
thing there because I think maybe most
people think they're in the middle,
like they probably think it no matter
what.
Like they,
if they're not destitute and if they're
not worth $20,
million bucks,
you probably think basically you're in
the middle.
Yeah.
So it's a way of making it,
about you,
even if it's actually not the case.
Your question,
if I'm not sure exactly exactly why it
caught by,
this myth caught on and it has held on
with such tenacity.
This myth has been going,
has been around now for 20 years.
It started in the mid 19 nineties and it
was actually an economist.
He's now at southern,
at Smu in Dallas.
He was at the time at an economist at
the Dallas Fed guy named Mike Cox,
and he's the first one who really
started looking into this.
I said,
well,
let's,
let's look at various measures of living
standard.
Let's look at how much ordinary people
are consuming today compared to in the
mid seventies.
This will kind of,
let's let,
let's,
let's look at what happens when we
adjust for income using better
inflation.
Adjusters come,
uh,
Mike Cox Found that my work is
derivative of my cox is that once you
start doing this,
this whole middle class stagnation thing
just crumbled into dust.
It's just not true.
It's not to say that there are no
problems.
It's not to say that the middleclass
wouldn't be even wealthier,
had not had,
they'd been better policies in place.
Whatever you think those policies might
be,
but it is to say that it's just crazy to
believe that an ordinary American or an
ordinary American family in 2018 has a
standard of living that is
indistinguishable from that of an
ordinary American family in 1975.
Yeah.
Do you know what basically the economics
look like if you're considered in the
middle class right now,
like the economics there really like
numbers that you look at on both sides
and go,
all right,
that's what middle class is because I
think that's part of the problem.
It is this sort of a morphis term.
Yes.
Yeah.
Uh,
I,
I don't believe that they are the,
the Census Bureau.
Among others,
they will divide household income into
quintiles.
Uh,
I don't recall what those numbers are at
the moment,
but a common definition should take the
three middle quintile.
So you'd get rid of the top 20 percent.
You were at the bottom 20 percent.
You have the middle 60 percent.
That's the middle class and upper
middle,
lower,
middle.
Uh,
but the Census Bureau does something
interesting from time to time it out.
So it divides household income and two
different categories,
less than 15,000,
15,000
to 25,000
on it and on up to like I think 250,000
and above and attracts adjusting for
inflation.
It tracks household incomes over time
and you can in a perverse way finding
these data that the middle class in
America is disappearing.
Right?
But it's disappearing into the upper
classes.
If you look at the percentage of
households in America who are earning a
in the lowest percentages,
right?
They're shrinking the only,
the only categories in which the
percentage of households in the US are
increasing or in the upper income
levels.
And so actually I think the very lowest
it might have ticked up a little bit
like the blessed in $15,000.
But in the great middle they have fewer
households percentagewise earning in
those categories today,
but more earning $100,000
annually and above.
And so in one sense,
yes,
it's tricky,
but it's getting Richard,
there is no evidence that we're getting
poor.
There's no evidence that it
meeting.
Yeah.
So we talked a little bit in an
ancillary way about taxes earlier,
so I'm not an economist,
but I'm going to lay out what I think is
sort of a fair tax system that's
consistent with all the ideals that
we've talked about here.
And I want you to probably get.
Have I had my ideas either I'm going to
be either I'm going to blow your mind or
you're going to tell me that I'm way
off.
So something like this,
this is what I've said a couple times,
is that I'm basically four attacks a
flat tax.
You don't get rid of exemptions.
Let's say it's about 15 percent,
but we can.
We can fiddle with the numbers,
but it's about 15 percent.
I would exempt everyone making let's say
less than like 40 grand,
maybe even 50 grand so that they have a
little more disposable income that they
can do things which,
which I think is good for them and good
for the economy.
And then just because I'm still,
I still have a little bit of a guilty
liberal in me.
I would even be willing to do some sort
of progressive tax if you're over say 10
million a year or something like that,
even though I know it's not right,
and I'm sure you can get rid of that by
the end of this conversation,
but there's still a piece of me that
says that,
but basically saying that for the huge,
vast majority of the country,
15 percent lidl exemptions may be a
little trickery on the high end.
I think that's consistent with the sort
of classical liberal idea of minimal
involvement and,
and equality of opportunity and what
you're all paying in.
And hopefully we'd call it a slimmer
trimmer government,
you know,
so.
So some glimmering in your eye.
Yeah.
So,
so as I said earlier,
I think one of the distinguishing
features of an economist has always yes.
Compared to what?
Right.
As compared to what we have now.
I mean,
that's,
that's close to.
Perfect.
All right.
I'll take it as compared to what my
actual ideal would be,
given that we're going to have taxes,
it's not quite my ideal.
I would indeed get rid of the,
the,
the progression at.
That's just the guilty part of me.
I think that still exists.
So the way I look at the way I look at
people who earn those kinds of incomes,
assuming they earn,
and most of them do,
they earn these incomes in the market.
That means that these people are
especially good at making life better
for ordinary Americans.
They're especially good at creating
jobs.
They're especially good at increasing
the value of my 401k.
But what would you say when people say,
but they don't need eight yachts and
helicopters and all that?
Uh,
I would say they earned.
It's theirs.
It's not up to me to say what they are.
It's their money.
I can make an argument against that.
I know is there's a lot.
Again,
your system is better than what we have
now,
but definitely if we're going to have
income,
taxation of flat tax and I'm willing to
have the exemption for the lower lower
incomes,
flat taxes,
the way to go.
Uh,
uh,
not only does it prevent a lot of
political chicanery messing with
brackets and,
uh,
but it,
it is economically a better system when
you tax all income earning activities at
the same rate than the relative prices
of different types of labor services
stays the same.
When you have progressive taxation,
you create greater distortions in the
economy and that,
that makes us as an,
as,
as a,
as residents of this economy.
It makes us all a little bit less
wealthy than we otherwise we'd be
because the economy has to deal with
these distortions.
So what do we do about spending?
Because at the end of the day,
that seems,
at least when we're talking about this
from a government perspective,
it's really all about spending that you
can tax out the Wazoo and regardless of
whether that tanks the economy or,
or fixes it or whatever,
that that's almost irrelevant.
If you just keep spending,
especially because of the amount of debt
we have and we're,
we know we're never going to pay it
back.
Which is why it's probably good that we
have a lot of bombs,
but that's a whole other.
That's a whole other discussion,
um,
you know,
because one day if China calls him the
debt lateral,
but,
but how do you reign in spending,
because this seems to be the thing that
all the trump people,
right?
They all thought he was going to reign
in spending this on quite the opposite
pack.
And,
and it's,
it's,
I think it's more than ever before.
It is.
So I think the big question,
I don't know how to do it.
We can speculate about changing the
constitution,
put in constitutional balanced budget
amendments,
constitutional caps on spending.
I'm skeptical of all of those things.
Government has many ways to get around
these,
these paper tiger provisions.
Uh,
the problem is the problem is Americans
today look to government and they,
and they,
they basically,
you're spending other people's money and
so if you're spending other people's
money,
it's easy to spend.
My,
my former colleague,
Russ Roberts had a piece in the Wall
Street Journal many years ago entitled
something like if you were paying,
I'm having steak.
So imagine,
you know,
imagine that we all go to a restaurant
and you know,
the different menu items,
right?
Well,
you can go to a restaurant and you and
you're picking up your part of the tab,
right,
you,
you may order a steak,
but that's because it's worthwhile to
and you will have to pay for it.
Uh,
but you might,
if you have to pay for you might not
already sick,
it might order a,
a less expensive dish,
but if it's going to be even,
it's just to be shared,
then based then the bulk of your extra
expenditure is shared with the people
you're going to dinner with.
And that's true for every person that,
that dinner.
Right?
And so you wind up with this bizarre
circumstance where every person acting
rationally winds up ordering too much
winds up asking of the restaurant too
much.
We wind up asking if our too much,
but we have to pay for it.
The resources do not fall out of the sky
free.
They're coming from somewhere.
And,
and because we're spending too much,
we're taking resources from where they
would be better used and putting them
were really,
none of us want them to be used,
but we all wind up using them there.
I know you said before that an anecdotal
story is not proof of a bigger theory,
but as you're saying that,
it reminded,
I don't think I've ever said this
publicly publicly before at my brother's
Bachelor Party when I was a struggling
comic and I had no money.
You know,
I had maybe 50 bucks in my pocket.
I don't know.
I was the best man.
All his friends were in banking and
lawyers and they all had money.
Big rollers were at a fancy one.
The one fancy plays the Borgata in
Atlantic City,
the one fancy nice place in Atlantic
city.
And we're sitting around this huge table
at a really super fancy restaurant and
um,
and all the entrees are 80,
9,000
bucks.
And I'm looking at him like,
you know,
what am I going to do here?
I was going to get the chicken for maybe
50 bucks or something.
And I was sitting with my,
my brother's one friend who also was
kind of struggling like I was.
We're both saying,
all right,
we're going to get the chicken for 50
bucks.
We go around,
everyone's getting steak,
lobster,
steak,
lobster.
It gets to my friend Josh.
He,
he's the whole time he's gone.
I'm getting the chicken.
The waitress says,
what do you want?
He goes,
lobster.
And then I just said steak like that,
like,
and it's exactly what you're talking
about.
You suddenly lose concept of what's in
your pocket somehow.
It's gonna Happen,
right?
It gets the bill's going to be shared.
Then the,
the,
the additional cost to you of ordering
states adopt a tiny fraction of the
actual additional cost to the steak.
And that's the problem with,
with government today.
We have people in Washington spending
other people's money for the benefit of
yet other people.
And when you do that,
you just get too much,
too much spending.
Uh,
we,
we've,
I don't know a better way to say it,
it doesn't sound very economic
understand,
but we've lost the ethic of respecting
other people's property once government
gets money,
once government officials figure out
something that they fancy is,
is,
is good,
and it may or may not really be good.
Uh,
which doesn't mean necessarily it's
worthwhile,
but maybe a good project that doesn't
mean that therefore we should go ahead
and spend money on it.
Uh,
there's an insufficient connection
between the spending and the,
and the,
and the experience of the cost of the
resources that go into the spending.
How much of this do you think is not an
economic problem but a political problem
so that if a politician was to get this
right,
let's say there's some magical
politician out there who really
understands economics,
but he knows if he goes to the Senate.
So I suspect rand Paul's kind of like
this.
I think he basically gets this and he
does fight the best fight generally that
I think he can,
but that they,
these guys want to get reelected and
saying to people,
we're going to spend less on you even
though you know it's.
It's the best thing we can do for you.
Actually,
it's going to free you up one day and
it's not going to tank the economy and
make us slaves to a foreign nation and
all that.
It just doesn't work politically because
it's not the easy answer of people more.
I think it's exactly right.
Let's face it.
Each politician has a timeframe that
extends to the next election.
Right?
So in the case of members of the house,
that's the only two years case of the
president.
That's four senators,
six,
that's not a long time frame.
Anything beyond that timeframe is
irrelevant to that person politically
today or to make it relevant.
That person has to have an ethic that is
very rare and unusual among politicians
and people with that ethic tend not to
be,
not to succeed in politics.
Handful do manage to get in,
but very few.
So you have people without that ethic
and they're just looking towards the
next election,
which is at most,
again,
only two years away for house member and
so if the bill is coming due two and a
half years from now,
if the,
if whatever other costs are going to
happen,
two and a half years from now,
uh,
or,
or alternatively,
if,
if taking some action that's only going
to,
it's going to have costs today,
but,
but huge benefits,
no matter how huge two years from now,
four years from now,
I'm not going to take it because it's,
that will do nothing to get them past
that next hurdle which is getting
elected reelected.
So in a very depressing sense or in a
sort of dystopian future sentence,
are we in a certain way?
Are we on a pathway to destruction no
matter what?
If you think about it,
I mean if you take that line of thinking
long enough,
right?
So we have a sort of weak political crew
dealing in ways that are the reverse of
how economically we can be successful.
Pretty,
pretty much always going off the off the
cliff.
So despite all that upset,
I remain optimistic and I'm not,
I'm not sure why I feel the same way.
I remain optimistic.
Um,
we,
we still have a respect for private
property in the United States.
We were still a very entrepreneurial
culture.
Uh,
uh,
we still hold politicians to.
Some of this is less now,
but to some level of,
of responsibility,
I say that,
um,
my libertarian friends are going to get.
We're saying I think there's something,
there's something there,
a look with the political problem has
always been there.
I think the US Constitution in the past
up until about eight years ago maybe did
serve more as a constraint that has
largely been shoved away.
But by and large,
we've still prospered over the past 80
years,
uh,
almost in spite of ourselves.
So this something is something in the
American mindset that something in our
gumption,
and I don't want to sound like a mobile
Rah Rah,
but there's something about this society
of ours that remains,
remains relatively open,
remains relatively free property.
Private property rights remain
relatively secure.
I think we still have something of a of
a rule of law in in place and what I've
learned in the 40 or so years that I've
been pondering these issues is that a
free society is far more robust than I
once believed it to be,
which is not to excuse or justify any of
the abuses that it takes,
but it's really robust and I have no
good sense of where the point is.
I don't believe it's indestructable.
Yeah,
but I have no good sense of where the
point is where you hit that point and
suddenly things are destined to go into
the,
into the gutter.
We may be moving there now.
I have a 21 year old son for his sake.
I certainly hope we're not close to
that,
but my gosh,
if you look back to the 19 thirties,
I think things will even worse than
idealize governed.
You know,
the,
the trend of government wise than they
are today and yet we did pretty well.
I'm glad that you just said idealize
because one of the things that I focus
on here is talking about ideas for
matter.
That's,
that's the whole purpose of what I do.
Do you think that these ideas related to
freedom and the individual and laissez
faire capitalism and all of the things
that we've discussed here are taking
root again,
because that's how I started.
You mentioned my interview with Thomas
Soul right before we started and I sense
it,
and again,
this is.
I can only tell you what I'm personally
feeling and what,
what I.
The feedback I get and all that,
but I said to Thomas or to Dr Saul,
I said,
do you realize that the renaissance of
your work is having and I think he's
Kinda,
he's Kinda just over it personally.
I think he's proud of his work,
but I,
they shouldn't be.
Yeah.
And of course they shouldn't be,
but I think just on a personal note,
he's kind of like,
yeah,
I've been doing this for a long time and
that's great,
but I really sense these things are
taking root again,
even though the mainstream media won't
let you really believe that and they
still will always elevate the people
that are pushing a lot of the more
socialist stuff instead of some people
with some.
So getting,
getting back to something we said
earlier,
I think it took a lot of people by
surprise in the late 19 seventies when
the ideas for cutting marginal tax rates
directly deregulation,
uh,
took hold.
And I think that's because people like
Milton Friedman,
uh,
my,
my late colleague James Buchanan had
been working years earlier in helping to
hire years early attempt to make these
ideas sound and,
and accepted.
And they were in place.
And when the crisis of the seventies hit
those ideas had an effect.
A No one knows the future.
The future is not destined to repeat
itself in the way that it did then.
But there are a lot of really good
people are you,
you're doing great work.
Uh,
there are a lot of really creative young
people today push refining these ideas,
polishing ideas,
presenting them to the general public in
new and more interesting ways and uh,
maybe it's a hope over experience.
Maybe that hope over,
I hope over reality.
But I actually believe that these ideas
are strong.
I think they are appealing and there
they are out there and well today in our
made 19,
May,
2018,
we can't see when they'll take root,
but I think that they will in fact
protect us.
That's a.
So that is the optimist in you and I
have that too because otherwise,
how could we do what we do?
Right?
I mean if,
if the answer,
if you would look to me 10 minutes ago
and said,
yeah,
pretty much.
We got to go off the edge there then
one,
then I would have had some of the booze
you have about behind Mr.
let's just so drinking right now.
Just wait for Armageddon.
Yeah.
No,
I,
look,
I believe.
Here's something that I did not fully
appreciate 20 years ago that I do
appreciate it now.
Twenty years ago I was a more hard nosed
economist.
Now ideas are really irrelevant.
They don't matter that much.
It's,
it's,
you know,
you know the institutional constraints.
I do think institutional constraints
matter.
They're important,
but I've come to see ideas as by far the
single most important constraint and
fuel for a society largely affected by
the work of Deirdre mccloskey.
For.
Thank you,
pat on.
It was one of my favorite shots that met
you.
Interviewed deirdre's work has
influenced me greatly and her work.
She's not the only one,
but she's done more than any other
modern economists to make the case for
the role of ideas and I think she's
correct.
She's correct in that.
So in that you must be incredibly
helpful then because I mean,
I feel the idea revolution.
I'm on tour with Jordan Peterson now and
I keep going up there and saying there's
an,
there's the right kind of revolution
happening.
We're not killing each other in streets
yet.
And how does that get stopped by an idea
revolution?
Yeah.
And so at the beginning I mentioned that
I came to economics because I was
impressed how economics explained
they'll gasoline shortages in the 19
seventies.
So I know if you remember a few years
ago,
you know,
gasoline,
Obama was in office,
gasoline prices are rising,
people are complaining.
Here's the importance of idea ideas.
There were,
there were no serious calls,
even the in the Obama administration to
go back to 1970 style price caps on an
energy.
I took that as a,
as a,
as a good sign that's saying it won't
happen in the future,
but I believe the reason that was the
case is because the economists who ics,
Milton Friedman and among the others who
explain the devastating roles of price
ceilings on energy,
those ideas was still around.
They was still out there,
still out there and they prevented
anyone who would propose such policies
seriously from being taken seriously.
And so that,
that notion of returning to the
seventies style price caps just never
got a hearing a few years ago when
gasoline prices were high.
So that,
that,
that that's one,
a data point that supports our optimism.
Yeah,
that,
that's great.
I mean,
I,
you know,
it's a long game,
right?
I mean that,
that's the point.
It is a long game.
I want to talk a little bit around
regulation before,
before we wrap up,
I had a,
you may know him,
the biology professor,
Bret Weinstein,
who's been on the show and he said he's
a friend of mine.
Uh,
he made an interesting comment to me the
other day.
I think maybe he tweeted it out and then
we discussed it a little bit
about,
well,
if you're,
if you're taking the true libertarian
approach and you're against all
regulation,
will,
are you saying that you want no
regulation over the airlines for
example?
They have any safety regulations or
anything like that and what?
We didn't have a ton of time to get into
the conversation.
I said,
I said Brett,
very quickly,
what I would say is I think airlines are
in the business of getting people from
one place to another and they do all
their due diligence and if the idea of a
government bureaucrat coming in to make
sure that this little thing is this way
as if they have more knowledge about it
than the airline people,
I find that to be pretty faulty,
but,
but we sort of left the conversation
there.
What do you,
what is the right amount of regulation
as a,
as a Libertarian,
oh,
I'm in favor of huge amounts of
regulation and I'm not being facetious.
I love regulation.
I believe the best regulator really
given this is the market.
It's a competitive market,
is consumers being able to spend their
money,
uh,
as they choose and,
or not to spend it as they choose.
It's the freedom of different,
uh,
producers and entrepreneurs to enter
markets or leave markets as they choose.
It's the competition among producers.
That's where real regulation comes from.
The market regulates activities.
You're,
you're right about the incidence of
airlines.
For example.
Uh,
no one has a stronger incentive to make
sure that a multimillion dollar piece of
machinery doesn't just willy nilly fall
out of the sky,
then the owner of that multimillion
dollar piece of machinery,
namely the airlines or the company that
they're,
they're renting it from.
And so the competition among the
airlines,
the,
the need for them to protect their
investments,
that is a tremendous source of
regulation and it's a very nuanced
source of regulation.
It gets it right and it's not subject to
political control or political
manipulation.
So a government.
So government regulation is too often,
uh,
actually deregulation in the worst
sense.
It's government relieving businesses
have the need to be as responsive to
consumers as they would otherwise need
to be.
So we,
we,
we call for example,
uh,
occupational licensing.
And that's a form of regulation.
Well,
no,
it's a form of deregulation,
deregulation.
It deregulates the,
uh,
existing producers in the market from
having to be as responsive as they
otherwise would to consumers.
So for example,
this would be like you have to have a
license to cut hair,
California.
Yeah.
And so if,
if,
if I,
if I'm a hair braider or a barber a or,
or an electrician,
and if this,
if the government prevents people from
entering in competition with me,
that makes my life easier.
I don't have to be as responsive to
consumers.
I can charge higher prices,
I could supply a less high quality
services.
And so I am deregulated in fact by that.
So called regulation.
Basically you would say it's the risk
you have to take to be free,
right?
So that in other words,
that if you're an electrician and I have
somebody come into my kitchen,
we had a little light thing the other
day now.
Yes.
The guy who was licensed,
I guess because it's got to be licensed,
but you're saying it's just the risk
that you have to take.
He
doesn't want to come in here and burn my
house down,
nor do you want him to do it.
Right.
This is another unintended consequence
of so,
so called government regulation in that
if people come to depend on it too much,
they just assume whoever you call up,
call up and say,
you know,
I,
I need some electrical work done in my
house.
Well,
we live in a state where electricians
are regulated,
so this guy must be okay.
Um,
uh,
maybe,
maybe not,
but if you knew that was up to you to
check,
first of all the market supplies,
all these wonderful ways of verifying a
quality.
So if,
if anyone was free to practice being an
electrician,
a,
you would have easy access.
You as a consumer,
we have easy access to various
mechanisms to,
to,
to rank various electricians by how,
especially in a video and all the apps.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Yeah.
So it's,
it's,
it's a total myth to think that the
government is more concerned about our
welfare and our property.
Then we are who's more concerned about
your house than you are,
who's more concerned about your personal
safety and health?
Then you are a.
The government might pretend that it's
more concerned or that it's somehow has
deeper insight to what is best for you,
but I don't buy it.
Uh,
I think,
I think young children,
uh,
they are,
they don't know their interest as well
as their parents do,
but once you become an adult,
the presumption must be that each of us
is an adult cares for and knows our best
interests much better than any third
party does reminded of something else
right now.
I think maybe I got too many of my old
economic theories from the simpsons
because do you remember that episode
knew very early on with Mr Burns at the
power plant and he's leaking,
you know,
nuclear waste into the river and they
get a three eyed fish and the whole idea
being,
if you just let business do what it
wants,
it's going to pollute the river and
you're going to be eating three eyed
fish.
But that's completely the reverse of
everything you've said.
So.
So,
so what,
what an economist would say to that as
well,
you know,
there are some areas where,
uh,
your actions as a private citizen spill
over onto a innocent third party so they
have no input.
So reasonable people can disagree about
the proper role of government in
preventing pollution or,
or preventing third party effects.
But so much regulation has nothing to do
with third party effects.
It's simply to say,
you know,
if you want to get your hair braided a,
you have to go to one of these people
that we approve,
you're not allowed to go to that person
over there,
uh,
who,
who does not yet have our approval.
Well,
there's no third party effect here.
And a surprising amount of regulation is
of that sort.
Yeah.
I mean,
I remember when I bought this house and
you have to have all the people come by
and the inspectors and everything and
they're looking for these little absurd
things that I'm talking with the builder
about it,
well,
this has to be an inch this way over
here and blah blah blah.
And it's like,
there was no answer for it.
I mean,
a couple of times I say,
well,
why is that regulation to regulate?
That's how it is.
Someone in Sacramento's said this is how
it should be,
and then that's how it is and everybody,
everybody.
So another problem with government
regulation is that it's one size fits
all and I don't care how smart you are
or,
uh,
how,
how much experience you have in the
past,
particularly in our highly dynamic,
in our highly dynamic economy.
Things are always changing.
Different people have different risk
tolerances.
Um,
so one of my least favorite regulators
is the FDA.
Uh,
there are very few third party effects
with the FDA.
The FDA is a,
a drug regulation affects you and it
prevents you in consultation.
If you choose with your doctor.
And most sensible people would consult
with a physician from choosing what
level of risks you are able to subject
yourself to in order to relieve yourself
of pain or to,
to,
to fend off imminent death.
I don't believe that any bureaucrats
business but yours.
You may make a decision different than
differently than I do,
but so what we all have different
tastes.
We all have different preferences,
preferences,
we all have different tolerances.
I don't believe that it's the
government's position to say,
no,
no.
Your preference for risk is too great.
We're not going to let you take this
experimental drug because we think it
might hurt you.
I don't see that's the government's
business at all at your business.
Right.
And you better get as educated as
possible.
I mean,
this is where I would say it comes down
to education and,
and,
but,
but who has a better incentive to become
informed and educated on the matter then
you,
it's your life.
Yeah.
Right.
And,
uh,
yes,
you can tell stories.
Well,
you know,
maybe you won't,
but I can tell stories too.
Well,
how do you know that this bureaucrat
over here is going to do as good a job?
I'm willing to bet that you are much
less likely to,
to be,
uh,
a less careful.
Yeah.
With your life than this guy or gal is
with your life.
Yeah.
All right.
So since you said it was a long game,
and I know how much high Eq has
influenced you and you right at cafe
[inaudible] dot com.
Let's do what are the ideas of how got,
I know we've actually explored a lot of
them here,
but if there was something that,
uh,
I told you before that a lot of my
audience,
they go out and they,
they get books after and they start
reading on all of this.
What are some of the ideas of high that
you'd like to impart?
That society is vastly more complex than
we understand it to be particularly a,
a market oriented global society?
You know,
we talk about it in vague terms about
the labor market,
the amount of trade,
you know,
the,
the GDP numbers,
all these terms and numbers mask,
enormous underlying complexities.
All the action that makes our society
work is done at the local level.
Uh,
and that,
that's a core hierarchy and insight.
And if you start acting at this,
at the higher level,
the risk is that,
that you will stamp out,
you'll,
you'll see a stomp out,
you'll smother these individual
adjustments.
At the local level that actually bob,
whose consequences bubble up to the top
to make it all work.
There's a great hire he,
he's not the most quotable of,
of guys,
but there's a great hire quotation.
I'm not going to get it exactly right,
but it goes something like the curious
task of the economist is to,
uh,
remind me again of how little they know
about what they imagine they can create.
Right?
So,
you know,
we can imagine Bernie Sanders imagines
he can create a world of everywhere.
Everybody gets paid at least $15 an
hour.
The other people imagine they can create
a world in which in which no one is dies
because of a drug overdose.
Well,
well,
you can create that world.
It's far too complex and that's the,
that's the critical hierarchy.
And inside the world's really complex.
And therefore for truly complex,
we want to devolve decision making
authority down to the lowest possible
level and not have people who are
slathered in Hubris,
uh,
making decisions for those of us on the
ground.
On that note,
I think you're an excellent communicator
of those ideas.
That's what it's all about,
right,
and it's reciprocated that very much.
And for more on Don Checkout,
Cafe High Eq Com.